francisco le pregunto cómo sería el
camino rumbo a la constituyente
angela buenas tardes el presidente
castillo ha dicho que va a someter su
proyecto de ley al parlamento y él va a
ser respetuoso de todos los
procedimientos él confía que el congreso
recibe ese proyecto lo analiza en los
debates y luego procede a convocar una
asamblea constituyente y esto que sea
sometido a referéndum pero para que esto
suceda el castillo necesita una mayoría
absoluta es decir 87 votos pero perú
libre su partido solamente cuenta con 37
sufragios en diversos entendidos en la
materia señalan que ni haciendo alianzas
con otros partidos políticos casi o
podría llegar a alcanzar los 56 votos y
esto no va a ser viable porque este
congreso es de derecha y las fuerzas de
oposición que son digamos amigables con
keiko fujimori han anunciado semanas
atrás que no van a permitir cualquier
tipo de iniciativa que contemple la
modificación de la carta magna que fue
aprobado por el ex presidente alberto
fujimori en 1993 algunos políticos de
otras agrupaciones están sugiriendo al
presidente
el castillo que presente una cuestión de
confianza al proyecto para que esto
pueda surtir efecto pero esto en
realidad sería un arma de doble filo
porque los legisladores podrían sentirse
presionados y en medio de esta
confrontación podrían aplicarle a
castillo un proceso de impeachment o
vacancia presidencial y eso nuevamente
pondría al perú en medio de otra nueva
crisis política